hey everybody it's Mike from autoflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about you know
big uh big orders hitting the markets
okay and sort of its importance and how
to uh use it in your analysis or as
you'll see not use it
um but before I jump in if you've been
enjoying my videos be sure to subscribe
to the channel click that notification
Bell so you don't miss any new uploads
and if you find today's video helpful be
sure you hit that like button for me and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway you know I love hearing your
feedback and you know a little goal of
going through your comments especially
the positive ones you know it sort of
gives me motivation to keep uh putting
out videos just like this so your
support really does go a long way all
right so let's go ahead and talk about
today's topic now you know s PS it's
about lunchtime right now what is it
it's September 26th it's Tuesday
um just just right at lunch time and you
know since the cash open
all right here okay this red line is the
low of the day you know we opened up in
the cash session right around the lows
and then we just kept selling off
selling off now we got a little bit of a
bounce here after this 920 low where we
traded down to 43 uh 25.
and
then we have a big order coming through
the market okay
all right you can see here Market was 28
basically uh you know
28 28
and a quarter
then it jumps from 28 and a quarter all
the way up to 30. and there's a big
sweep going through the market how do I
know that this is a market sweep is
because there's no counter trade right s
PS trade you know contracts every Split
Second and someone just came in here and
swept through the order book
they just basically put in order to buy
you know whatever about two and a half
thousand up to forty three Thirty how do
I know it's about two and a half
thousand because this is 133 113 140 130
144. you add all this up you get about
1200 even plus the 233 and I see another
1200 sitting on the bid here so that's
about two and a half thousand now all
the guys that are trading on a dome you
know trading on a heat map or something
like that a book map they're looking at
that they see that big aggressive order
come through they have a tendency to
want to sort of jump in front of it
right because you know hey if there's a
big Trader coming in the market
that means something right so okay yeah
if I could go alongside of him it's sort
of like you know the the the great white
shark in the ocean
right the big traitor is the great white
shark the guy that bought two and a half
thousand and all the you know all the
guys trading on their Dome and the heat
map they're they're sort of like the
those you know you've seen the pictures
right of the shark and there's those
little fish swimming around because
they're picking up the scraps you know
those are the people jumping right ahead
of them at uh
30 and a quarter okay so let's just mark
this area on our chart here okay so just
Mark that area 43 30.
but what was interesting is it was a
zero follow through Market didn't go any
higher than this bar and in fact in the
next bar we trade back down into where
the sweep took place from
and then again over the next one two
three four five bars we literally cover
that whole area of the sweep right and
then we went back up
we sort of reversed it went back all the
way up to 35. now
laughs
when I see a big order coming through
the market like this what I'm expecting
is
if it's sort of you know I want to say
real money or something like that
because you know it is it's a gigantic
course two and a half thousand that just
happened just like that I'm really
looking for this Market to make its move
quickly then when we get up here to 35
you can see the volumes on the offer 900
1100 1300 now this word gets interesting
this was about two and a half thousand
bought at thirty it's about two and a
half thousand sold at 35. is it the same
guy I don't know
maybe maybe not I don't know I mean hey
do anything good
if you could pull off uh
you know what is that Five Points this
is the minis
you know what is that 250 bucks times
two and a half thousand contracts you
know that's 625 000
um in about 10 minutes I know again I
don't know if that's the same guy or not
okay but I just found that the volume
interesting but what to me is the the
takeaway is I get the strong volume in
here I'm looking for this move to happen
right not sort of pull trade back all
the way back into it and then get sort
of this half-hearted move up to 35 where
it sort of runs into some size now when
we got up here to 35 okay so this could
be a potential resistance area forget
about what happened here for a second
right if you're coming up into sort of a
swing high and you see some heavy volume
come in maybe potentially this could act
as resistance okay the next bar you know
we're staying below it for the most part
for the next five six minutes then we
start trading above it well this is
where it's interesting if we're trading
on the other side of this 35 area that's
not a good sign of this being resistance
in the sense that just as here right if
I was looking at this as being support
trading below it is not a good sign and
more importantly you don't see that
Trader that buyer still in here or
Traders rather still in here supporting
this market so even though you got some
big size here
it's it's done right it's not supporting
that market anymore just as up here it's
not offering resistance anymore right
and that's what I talk about you know
with with the information that comes
from the order flow you want to take
advantage of it as soon as possible
all right so for example here right okay
I got some strong sellers in here right
ran into potential resistance starts
trading down okay good it's moving in my
direction if you get short then you just
go sideways sideways sideways sideways
sideways that's not a good effective
trade
that's your sign maybe you should get
out of it because it's not moving in the
direction that you want
right and eventually it comes back up to
that area of that heavy volume which
technically should be resistance and it
it's trading here you don't see that
resistance you just see sort of normal
order flow volumes going through here
and then we rally another seven eight
points before we start coming back down
okay
then we get back down now if this is not
a new low although the day was you know
25 and a quarter then we sort of come
back in
to this 35 area remember 35 we had the
strong seller there now we got what do
we got here right we get all the way
down to 32.
and a big buy comes through here another
big sweep comes through the market
right and again this is for again for
about two and a half thousand contracts
okay next bar
training above it great that's what you
like to see you know I don't need to
move my line because it's still at that
same level 35. next bar
yeah it's still green but it's not going
anywhere it's inside of this green bar
here then a red bar comes in here trades
down to 35 gets through it where is my
strong buyer
it's not there anymore
I know my strong buyer
is not there anymore
and we could get through this area what
do I think is going to happen we're
probably going to keep selling off just
as if I have a strong seller here
we sell off a little bit I mean it's not
a big sell-off it's about four points
then we come back up to that area 35 and
I don't have this strong seller here
anymore
what do I think is going to happen do I
think the Market's going to sell off no
this this strong seller is removed from
the market
so if I know that where I had Supply
earlier is removed from the market I'm
going to look for the market to go
higher which it did it went up another
eight points okay now remember don't
forget about this one here at 30 okay so
we get back down down to 30. is there
some strong support in here right
because remember earlier
again you know I don't want to say this
is support because we spent a lot of
time underneath it
but technically it did pull back to
where that strong aggressive buying
started down here at 28 and a half
if anything you know maybe 28 and a half
you know sort of be the low end if you
would where that sweep sort of started
okay if that but it comes down it tests
that area it gets down to 28th and a
quarter again the first time but you're
not seeing the strong buying that you
saw earlier right I mean they did trade
back down to 28 and it did go up to 32
but
you know or from 30 rather up to 32 and
a half then later pulls back down into
you know 28 and a half and then it just
sort of hangs around I'm not seeing some
strong support necessarily coming in and
eventually it breaks down gets down
closes on the other side of that area
and heads down to new lows
okay now this time we get down to this
new low at 21 and three quarters again
another sweep came in this time it's not
as powerful as these earlier sweeps you
know it's 100 200 300 400 500 600 7 800
you know so maybe about a thousand you
know between 22 and a half and you know
we'll call it 24 and a half right up in
here
okay
now obviously it's a stacked buying and
balance but you know if you just sort of
draw your line I don't know somewhere in
here
okay next bar we trade down into that
then we trade sort of back up into that
28 and a half to 30 area
again not quite getting through but
you're not necessarily seeing a strong
buying people say well look at they got
a thousand here yeah well it's a
thousand on the bid thousand on the
offer that's just normal order flow
really what you want is where it stands
out you know if it was a thousand on the
bid and just 162 on the offer that in my
opinion would be more important okay and
then we just sort of hang around in
between these areas right so there's
nothing really to get too excited about
I mean you know we got a strong buyer
that came in here right off the low of
the day but is it holding yeah you know
for the most part again you know we're
sort of coming into the lunch time but I
don't see strong bids coming in
really until you get over here the 877
um but more or less at this point just
sort of going sideways so I guess you
know sort of the the point of this video
is when you first see some signs of you
know strong bids coming into the market
well in this case we're talking about
bids because we're at the low of the day
you want to see it acting as support
right because if you're going to jump in
in front of this bid at 30
you want to see it not just trade higher
initially in that bar but then in the
subsequent bars if you're trading below
it that's not a good sign chances are
we'll probably go a little bit lower now
that's not to say that you know you
couldn't have bought it here at you know
what is this 30 and a quarter sold it
out up here at
one and a quarter make a point I mean
you can if that's your your trading
style I think it's a little bit more
effective to try and get more points
um and then here right you got some
strong offers coming in
okay
Market starts trading down that's what
you want to see you want to see those
levels hold not really you know not hold
like here where it's trading immediately
through it in the next bar you want to
lease the next bar to be moving away
from it you know and again you know can
you make anything out of this well you
know maybe you could have got a point
out of it if that or maybe you just lost
a point because if it's not moving in
the direction that you want it to move
or I say wanted to move but expect it to
move
that's just not going to be a very
effective trade right and at some point
you got to say it's not moving
in the direction that I'm looking for it
to move
right and then that's when you cut it
because you know what even though you
know eventually because I'm not going to
say yeah well you know look at this
right it didn't it didn't sell off you
know well yeah but in the meantime it
rallied eight points against you
right so that that's not really an
effective trade just as here strong
buyers come in okay next bar is going up
okay
that's good good but then this this bar
is inside
okay that's not what you want to see on
a market that's moving right if a market
if a bar goes inside if you're looking
for a market to move and then it just
goes inside on you that's probably not
going to go the direction that you want
to me that's for me that's one of the
signs of a trade that's not going to
necessarily work out
okay so you got to look for these signs
you have signs and for me if a bar
that goes inside
that's not a good sign it's not an
encouraging sign right you want it to
start moving away
okay here it goes inside of this bar
right that's not what you like to see
you want to see a nice clear break up or
down
so anyway guys that's going to wrap up
today's video on sort of you know
recognizing the the strong volume coming
in and whether or not it's going to be
effective to actually take a trade off
of right oh one thing I just wanted to
touch on really quick
um this is the heat map okay
you see here well 600 came in here at 27
it's Market's going to the moon no
um because if you you know because guys
that like heat Maps you know they'll say
well you see how you know there's strong
bids coming in here uh 400 600 in the
market took off okay well earlier
all right and then this is you know
things like a sweep right you can't see
it right let's just open this up here
because it happens so fast it's not
going to show up as liquidity so this
was that low right the sweep came in
where was it in this bar here I believe
yeah 30. right do you see
you know big volumes that means 367 here
it's 284.
all right even if you just go back one
bar I mean at 30 it was 223 again it
came in on the bid side so you're not
seeing it sort of pop in there as
liquidity because somebody just bought
everything up through it and worked a
bit here at
um at 30.
okay then when you got up to
uh where was it 35 okay do you see
anything up here at 35 or 35 here 211.
okay but we know about two and a half
thousand contracts traded right so it's
an iceberg order
236 still showing so obviously whoever's
doing it probably showing you know
100 or 150.
right okay 295.
oh there's a big offer there you know
there's all these guys will say he goes
look at that
you know look at this 285 okay fine you
know to me that's not considered really
big it would get through it okay
right trade on the other side of it
and then come right back down
so
when you're dealing with you know sort
of Market sweeps or big supportive
buying or
resistance selling right Supply it
doesn't necessarily show up in the
market depth because of where it's
coming in if it's coming in on the bid
side you're not going to see it in the
liquidity
because this liquidity is showing you
what's away from the market
right either below the market or above
the market
what you want to be watching is the
inside Market sort of you know what's
trading on the bid and the offer or more
importantly what traded on the bid or
the offer now that's not to say that you
know
the heat map isn't useful and there's
uses for it I mean sometimes you're
going to see like orders at a level that
just sitting there waiting to be picked
off especially in the night session
um you know and to be honest I've seen
book map I don't use it but um I've seen
it and it looks pretty neat they've got
some great features on it
um you know maybe one day
um
you know I'll if I have the time I'll
spend some more time looking at it but
um
again
that's just a different way of trading
but if you're looking for volume coming
in on the bid or volume coming in on the
offer when the market is trading right
there it's not going to show up as
resting liquidity because it's current
liquidity that's coming in right and
it's coming in very fast it's coming in
through a sweep right here through
several points coming in right here as
the market jumps from eight and a
quarter to 30 30 and a quarter why
because a big order just came in into
the market
all right guys so that's going to wrap
up this video on sort of big
liquidity coming in on the current bid
or the current offer so I hope you find
this video helpful
um someone what I talk about hopefully
you find it helpful and useful for your
Trading
um an understanding of order flow so let
me know what you'd like me to discuss
next by leaving a comment down below and
if you enjoyed this video and my other
videos make sure you hit that like
button and subscribe to my channel so
you don't miss any
more of my upcoming content all right
everyone have a great day and I'll catch
you guys on the next video bye bye